rund in Viertel vor die jungen Männer in
der Schweiz machen
kraftsportal ich meine wenn du
Reaktionen
und nehme das natürlich mit und geil ich
frage mich ab wann trainieren
aber wann macht bunte krank
[Musik]
jetzt treffe ich den gerade Bela er
macht Bodybuilding da in sarne er hat
mir schon am Telefon gesagt dass er
nicht das Leben
trainieren und das zum Teil über zwei
Stunden lang und ich frage mich was er
sich vor dem erhofft hey
freut mich
[Musik]
er ist fast jeden Tag im Studio und er
hat vom Besitzer sogar ein eigener
Schlüssel
gemacht
der Bela hat vor sieben Jahren mit dem
Pumpen angefangen
Kraftsport initial einfach aus dem Grund
will ich haben eine anders
über Social Media versucht er sich als
Business aufzubauen er bietet Coachings
an das macht der zusammen mit dem besten
Freund am Ramon das bin ich momentan
was ich mache warum also kleine insights
geheime momentane Prozess gibt's Profil
Beispiel
[Musik]
sehr sehr viele Sachen zusammen gemacht
Mensch war sehr sehr viele Sachen
zusammen erreicht und ja alles zweifache
Weltmeisterin und doch
im Rahmen
[Applaus]
der Plan ist jetzt das sind wir jetzt
wenn jetzt hier gefilmt
und nachher Pumpe
[Musik]
das sind 200 und 2020
ich merke Pumpe
und alles geschafft mit dem eigenen
Körper der eigene Ästhetik die beide
sagen sie würdet kein leistungsfördern
die Medikament wird zum Beispiel
Anabolika schließlich Betrieben sind
natural Bodybuilding was so viel heißt
wir Muskelaufbau auf natürlichem Weg
aber ohne Substanzen
akribisch fest und zeigt sie dann auf
Social Media
inszenieren
ich würde wahrscheinlich auch nicht
machen
extrem viel Luft also das
ja
natürlich cool wenn du auch positiv
Feedback bekommst
du bitte natürlich ist das ist das cool
und nehme das natürlich mit und ist geil
aber der Driver für im Training ist es
auf jeden Fall nicht
ich mache eine Pause und ich muss der
Akku wechseln und also obwohl es wird
wichtig ist hat doch
nur recht viel Liter und ja ich würde
sagen zu voll vernünftig
ich muss sagen
dass ich jetzt bin WLAN bin Filme
Pumpe Hobby oder sucht ich frage mich ab
wann wird der Sport schädlich wie weit
gönnt einzelne Männer für ihre Ziele im
Fitness ich bin unterwegs zu einem wo
erfahreige mit muskelfördernden Mittel
wie Anabolika gemacht hat
Daniel er hat im Internet
mit verschiedenen leistungsfördern
das ist schon Merkel Montenegro und ja
da sieht man total unproportional Buche
natürlich Standard
du bist voll gemein mit dem 50-Jährige
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
wo mehr nicht gefallen hat und es
scheint für mich verschnupft
oder
sieht der Stachel und da muss abhocke
und das ist halt irgendwann alle andere
Energie bitte und du bist Sport
Körperhaltung experimentierte damit
halt die Sachen ausprobiert Luger was
ein leichte Boot was was Maximum
und Medikament ausprobiert wo editiert
verwendet werden zum besseren trainieren
könnt übrigens unter anderem vor Akne
überschrumpfen die Horde bis hin zu
langfristige Niere und laberisch Angst
vor deiner negative Effekt
das einzige Laster
Zigarette ich bin beim recherchiert auf
der Begriff muskelsucht gestoßen
bereits wenn ich Muskel und dass man
davon trainieren das ist eine Service
mit dem identifizieren
ich merke dass ich ihm wichtig bis heute
trainierte Daniel regelmäßig er hat
sogar seine Fitnessraum umfunktioniert
[Musik]
ganz schwer
wenn
Familie also
wenn sie deutsch
aber Freunde
[Musik]
Definition
was machen
Minuten
oh Gott
Netflix
[Musik]
aufgehört hat gesund zu sein
ich habe das Gefühl dass wir ebens ganze
Fitness und Sport mache sich so viel
mehr ums Thema Leistung dreht und jetzt
gar nicht so fest um es Körperbild oder
Ästhetik
und
lecker
sind voll Arsch schießen und dann frage
ich mich so ist das gesund
mach das Sinn
bin unschlüssig zwischen gesund und
ungesund verlauft beim Pumpen
mich was ist denn die genaue Definition
von muskelsucht zum das User finde mache
ich mich auf der Weg zum Roland Müller
er ist Psychotherapeut und hat sich auf
dem Gebiet Körperbild Störung
spezialisiert und er trainiert selber
auch regelmässig
[Gelächter]
der Punkt oder wo das Ganze im Leben
eigentlich mehr ist
dass es grün gibt in der Bilanz
[Musik]
ich mache das hier für mich
ja klar macht es für dich aber warum
poste ich alle zwei Tage in dem face in
die Instagram Status es fällt mir nach
dem Fitness vorm Spiegel ohne T-Shirt
machst du das nur für dich
Praxis und sagen
ich hatte es Probleme mit dem
und das Buch dann schon Wesen und windig
oder Kontext würde dir gegeneinander
ja
vielleicht noch zu viel trainiert hat
und fünf sechs Mal war und einfach nur
ja stupides Krafttraining gemacht hat
und ja die Gelenke das haben sie auch
nicht so gefreut aber wenn man jung ist
verzeiht der Körper das dann auch also
so schlimm war es dann nicht
ja grundlegende Ergebnisse
ich merke es gibt nicht einfach gesund
und ungesund laut dem Roland ist es
Spektrum in dem man sich als Sportler in
bewegt zurück im Fitness in Sarnen ich
wollte wissen ob der Sport negative
Auswirkungen von Bela und vom Ramon hat
dass du dich defizitär
war nämlich
denn ist schlecht so oder aber wenn du
es machst und du dir aber bewusst bist
mit deiner Konsequenzen
Gefühl dass das per se Schlacht ist oder
schlachte ist dass du dich vielleicht
auch bisschen Personen halt dann schon
viel damit durch oder hat
das gemacht dass du eigentlich
ist ja Sachen gegangen bevor du
eigentlich wenn du ganz ehrlich mit der
Stelle beschnitten
[Musik]
und das sind alte Sachen
nämlich zu der Risikogruppe trotzdem
finde ich es wichtig nicht direkt
pauschalisieren und einfach alle Pumpen
aber ich merke das Thema muskelsucht
spielt für beide Rolle
livesticks und Bodybuilding also die
Mädels fallen nicht so eine
[Musik]